want to get more from your next workout
then here's a quick tip train outdoors
training outdoors means training in the
way that we evolved to Train and right
now not even the most fully kitted out
gym can come close to replicating that
when you go for a trail run outdoors for
instance your foot will hit the ground
at slightly different angles with each
strike the small muscles in your feet
and leg will have to respond and your
core will likewise need to engage and
help you balance remain upright that's
before you try running on sound through
shallow water or up hills a simple jog
becomes a full-body workout especially
when training barefoot or in minimal
footwear likewise when you climb a tree
or scramble up a verge you'll be
gripping onto differently shaped and
angled reaps and holds working your body
at different angles the same days for
curling a heavy rock or performing press
ups on the beach you'll train muscles
that get missed when performing the same
set patterns over and over in the gym a
tree can make an excellent sparring
partner or pull-up bar a log is an
excellent balance beam or a wide grip
barbell training like this will
strengthen your grip and toughen your
fashio plus it makes for fantastic
Instagram product being outdoors
likewise means getting to run through
different routes and views it's the
closest you get to being Sonic the
Hedgehog in real life which along with
being more like Batman rocky and Goku is
basically why I got into training in the
first place training outdoors means
training enriches stimulating
environments which are more likely to
trigger flow States and flood us with
dopamine and brain derived neurotrophic
factor conversely going for inspiration
walks and lush environments is one of
the best ways to boost creativity then
there's the fresh air and the Sun which
improves mood and energy increases
vitamin D and testosterone and helps to
set your biological clock so you sleep
more soundly meanwhile cold weather or a
dip in the water will help to increase
adrenaline and strengthen your immune
system shifting between extreme
temperatures will train your thermal
regulation few things will leave you
feeling as taxed and has beaten up as an
intense outdoor workout
real strength means being strong and
unpredictable angles and conditions and
there's nothing quite so unpredictable
and chaotic as nature